you go awesome awesome what's next up
here we go hmm
so this question
it's from from what medium because I'm
all confused now we're getting in from
every possible way this is an email
question so this is an email question
that came in to the website from maybe
Amala 93 okay
misery star talk radio next our talk
radio dotnet guy so we'll the Milky Way
collide with Andromeda yes oh dude no
next question yes we've I'm so glad we
cleared that we are so hos right we are
on a collision course with our nearest
large galaxy the Andromeda galaxy our
galaxies the Milky Way we've got several
hundred billion stars in this beautiful
majestic spiral orbiting a supermassive
black hole in our centre wow we are on a
collision course in mutual descent
towards our neighboring large galaxy
Andromeda also a system of several
hundred billion stars all in orbit
around in a central black hole so now
let me ask you if I may follow up on
maybe a mile of 93's questions I can say
when it would happen yeah well yeah but
here's what I want to know is that
because this massive black hole is
pulling both galaxies towards itself
yeah so I mentioned the black holes but
in fact they're not really relevant the
mass of all the stars far outweighs is
far more significant in this
gravitational embrace okay then the
black hole in the center I just added
that for flavor just for flavor
descriptive flavor right that's it right
right now
the Andromeda black hole is bigger than
the Milky Way's black hole you know I've
heard that about it drop its
michael Envy yes
there's supermassive black holes in the
center of every galaxy we've ever we've
ever observed okay so we're on a
collision course in about 5 6 billion
years will collide and stars are so far
apart from one another that they'll feel
each other's gravity but they're not
going to hit each other physically but
it'll be quiet
a cosmic
balle choreographed nice forces of
gravity and so if you were to speculate
what would that kind of look like
trainwreck real yes I was an awesome
frame we have images of other galaxies
but you know by the way this whole
ballet will take several hundred million
years okay I can't film it but there's
so many galaxies undergoing this in the
in the universe okay you can find some
that are near each other a little closer
a little closer in they're about to
collide colliding and so we have a sense
of what this would look like and it's a
beautiful train wreck stuff stars cast
hither and yon and it's a huge mess that
finally resettles into one massive
galaxy twice the size of what each one
was before so it does settle down and
become so so it would this be the the
equivalent of galactic sex
accepting baby galaxies don't come out
the other side oh that's the best kind
of sex there is but if the universe is
sex to you then there it is okay
oh man that was fascinating yeah good
stuff alright so we took another
question yeah okay oh by the way yes I
tweeted recently about the collision of
galaxies digit yeah and I said you know
in about six billion years seven billion
years the Milky Way will collide with in
drama then I said but not to worry
because the Sun will burn the earth to a
crisp by the heck I'm not gonna lose any
sleep now and that turned out to be one
of my most retweeted tweets of all time
I don't know why people just like
knowing dinner has died because it was
comforting we don't have to worry about
the galaxy colliding with Andromeda but
just every bright Sun will be vaporized
right and that's so much better
alright